سيكون استاذ الجوهره في جده الموسم القادم
على موعد مع الكلاسيكو كلاسيكو من نوع اخر
الاتحاد مقابل النصر وبنزيما المنتقل
حديثا الى دوري السعودي سيواجه زميله
السابق رونالدو في مباراه للتاريخ هذا في
الملعب اما في المدرجات سيكون هناك لقاء
ناري من نوع اخر يا ابراهيم بين جورجينا
صديقه رونالدو التي ستكون جنبا الى جنب مع
جارتها عارضه الازياء الفرنسيه مش مبين
عندي كويس فانت كمل احسن كوره
طيب اللقاء الكروي مشاهدينا لن يمنع من
توجيه الامطار الى اللقاء النسائي ايضا
خصوصا وانه العنصر النسائي بالنسبه
للاعبين له الكثير من الاهميه في قرار
الانتقال الرياضي
الامثله كثيره ابراهيم احد الامثله اللي
كانت على الانتقالات لكن خارج الرياضه
ايضا زوجاته صديقات اللاعبين جزء مهم من
القرار القرار بالانتقال بعضها كان تاريخي
وبالنسبه للاعبين بالضبط واخر كان مدمر
لمسيرتهم الكرويه ومستقبلهم صح بالتاكيد
طبعا خلونا نشوف علاء
[موسيقى]
بالفعل لعبت زوجاته اللاعبين دورا كبيرا
في حياتهم القصص كثيره ولعل احداثها حول
التاثير الكبير زوجه ليونيل ميسي التي
اصبحت حديثه الساعه بسبب الكلام عن رغبتها
في العوده الى برشلونه زوجه مارو ايكاردي
لاعب غالطه سرايا التركي حاليا وباريس سان
جيرمان السابق كان لها دور سلبي في
انتقالاته الكثيره ليفقد اللاعب مكانته في
المنتخب الارجنتيني فضلا عن فقدانه لبريقه
بعد تركه لانتر ميلان ايضا اللبنانيه
الاصل دانيلا سمعان كانت احدى اهم اسباب
انتقال زوجها نجم الكره الاسباني
الى برشلونه من ارسنال في صيف 2011 لتكون
قريبه من صديقتها زوجه ميسي وساهم الحب
الذي عاشه لاعب مانشستر سيتي السابق
وبرشلونه الحالي فيران توريس بانتقاله من
انجلترا الى
بسبب رغبته بالبقاء قرب حبيبته
لينفصل قبل ايام فقط بسبب عدم رغبتها
بالرحيل عن برشلونه وهو ايضا المهدد
بالبيع من قبل النادي الاسباني لضرورات
ماليه ورياضيه واخيرا وليس اخيرا تبدو
بلار روبيو زوجه المدافع الاسباني سيرجيو
راموس احدى المؤثرين المباشرين في مستقبله
القادم خصوصا بعد تصريحاتها الاخيره حول
مستقبله المجهول ورغبتها في المشاركه في
القرار النهائي لحسمه
[تصفيق]
على فكره هذا موضوع كثير مهم يمكن اعتقد
مناقشته مهمه لانها راح تاثر في قرارات
لاعبين كثير من ابرزهم ميسي على كل حال
ينضم الى نفر الاستوديو هنا الصحفي
الرياضي منير رحومه اهلا بك استاذ منير
الان يعني
سعيدين بوجودك معنا لكن الاجواء الان
مشحونه خصوصا حول صفقه انتقال ميسي لانه
البعض يقول بانه قرار انتقاله مرهوم
بزوجته واولاده هل الامر حقيقي وهل زوجات
اللاعبين باثروا كما تابعنا على قراراتهم
ومصيرهم الى اين ينتقلون بالتاكيد ابراهيم
يعني مثل ما ذكرت انه اليوم الوضع تغير
اليوم الزوجه لها دور كبير في حياه اللاعب
داخل الملعب وخارج الملعب داخل الملعب انه
عم يتوفر الظروف الملائمه لانه اللاعب
يبدع ويتالق يعني ويقدم افضل مستويات داخل
البيت يعني هي اللي بتقرر مستقبل ومصير
الاسره يعني العديد من يعني خاصه اليوم
اغلب زوجات
انا اللي حبيت اساله ولكن هناك الكثير من
العوامل تتدخل في اتخاذ القرار النادي
الذي سيخرج منه النادي الذي سينتقل اليه
وضع مسيرته المهنيه اي مرحله هو في مسيرته
المهنيه حتى يمكن او الوكيل له راي في
الموضوع مش بس النساء عشان نكون يعني
منصفين طبعا يعني انت خلاص يعني لكن
للامانه شوف يعني النساء مؤثرات بشكل كبير
انه في النهايه هناك مستقبل اولاد يعني
مثلا شفنا نجمه الغناء العالمي مثلا
شاكيرا عندما انتقلت من كولومبيا الى
العيش في اسبانيا واستقرت مع زوجي وفضلت
يعني التضحيه بمستقبلها المهني والفني
والبقاء مع زوجها عندما طبعا انفصل عادت
الى يعني كولومبيا لمواصله حياه الطبيعيه
اللي ترك ارسنال وراح الى برشلونه لانه
زوجته دانيلا بتحبك
ربما زميلنا في الاخبار ابراهيم هو اول
الضحايا الاخباريين لكن خلينا نقول بانه
الى اي مدى ممكن هذا يفتح الباب امام دي
ماريا مودريتش
مكانتي غيره من اللاعبين اللي من الممكن
انه يروحون السعوديه صحيح احد جورجينا
راحت بزوجه بنزين يعني جورجيني يعني
توجدها في السعوديه كانت تجربه ناجحه
ومريحه
بالضبط
السعوديه العربيه في الشرق الاوسط في على
مستوى التسويق والدعاء هذا بزنس ايضا
بالضبط يعني شاهدنا انه الاسره تتحرك بكل
راحه بكل اريحيه في البلد لا توجد اي
عوائق او مشاكل بالعكس هذا الامر بشجع
بقيه الزوجات اللاعبين المشهورين في
المقابل يعني في عناوين بتقول انه زوجات
اللاعبين
احنا كابوس يهدد عرش وكلاء اللاعبين هل في
الامر مبالغه يعني احيانا الصحف تبالغ
يعني في موضوع تاثير الزوجات يعني بكون
اللاعب عنده اسباب لا يريد ان يقول هل
يصرا عنها
على الزوجه وبالتالي هل تظلم النساء
وزوجات اللاعبين احيانا
في هذا الجانب هناك ايش اللي تتفق معه هذه
ليست يعني فقط بالنسبه للنساء تتحمل
مسؤوليات يعني اتخاذ مثل هذا امور فنيه
يعني هناك لاعبين لا يزالوا في اوجه
العطاء يعني لا يمكن ان يختاروا مثلا وجهه
تكون اقل من يعني مستواهم الفني
وامكانياتهم يعني على مستوى
ثلاثه حتى ربما زوجه صلاح كانت يعني مصدر
ضغط يعني كان ينتقد صلاح لاي تصرف تقوم به
زوجته رغم انها بعيده عن هذا العالم عن
الاضواء لكن كمان يعني يضغط على اللاعبين
خلال متابعه زوجاتهم وبالتالي السوشيال
ميديا يعني ربما تمثل الضغط على اللاعبين
يعني ابراهيم يعني اختلف الوضع يعني في
زمان مثلا ايام بيليه ايام مارادونا ممكن
اللاعبين 10 صديقات زوجات ولا احد يعلم
لكن اليوم اصبح اللاعب تحت المجهر هناك
تركيز كبير على حياه اللاعبين الخاصه
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات